[Musique]
en fait sur le moment j'étais choqué
effectivement j'ai pleuré ensuite je
savais qu'elle était déjà souffrant et
je me suis dit bah en fait voilà il y a
un ange il y a il y a quelque chose
puisque j'ai parlé d'elle à ce moment-là
et exactement 27 minutes après j'ai le
message donc je pense que quand je suis
arrivé à l'aéroport de Nice et qu'elle
habitait à côté son âme était là
puisqu'elle habitait 30 ans et que
c'était une façon de me dire au revoir
parce que moi je suis très spirituelle
et je crois à fond à Dieu parce que je
serai jamais là où j'en suis voilà mais
là je suis là pour rendre hommage à la à
l'icône Tina Turner à ma belle-mère
continuer à respecter le nom de Hackett
Tina Turner avec mes chansons avec mon
courage et les honorer parce que j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir été choisi par cette
famille et continuer la Legacy Turner et
i love you